uh okay talk to me about your your
crypto project
a coin now just help me understand
because I think a lot of people
are down on crypto in general right nfts
have taken a [ __ ] right the whole entire
whole Market fell well the whole entire
space is like it felt a little predatory
right right so I feel like you've gotten
some uh negative feedback for your
project explain your project and why it
is obviously is it still going on is
this that's the thing Acorn is African
coin okay so most of the things that's
that's happening in the US it doesn't
really affect us because we have our own
currency and mine was turning Mobile
minutes into currency because out there
you have to buy your minutes still right
yeah so it's a whole nother concept
whole number you know like our exchange
rate for minutes don't even exist in
America like because they don't you
can't turn your Mobile minutes into
actual spending money here yeah because
bandwidth in Africa is like less it's so
much less but a lot of people don't know
that cell phones have been operating in
Africa since 96. which way before he was
even operating here
like they so Advanced when it comes to
mobile and the the
um the kind of Technology you have for
mobile carriers is just on a different
level
so your your coin if somebody has a
phone plan in Africa and maybe they
don't use 100 minutes for the month
exactly they can convert those minutes
for groceries exactly wow that's dope
yeah so it's totally different but now
we're converting the wallet to where you
can be able to use it in the states and
I'll be launching that before the end of
the year oh that's dope and now what
about just the city that everyone says
you're building wakanda yeah it was a
condo
no I'm just joking it's a con City but I
play on that because the movie kind of
actually believe it or not the movie did
a lot for acon City because people never
knew that Africa could even be or could
look like that not realizing that we
were already in process of building a
smart City already before the movie so
before the movie came out you were
already in the world concept since 2010.
wow yeah but we just we literally just
starting the construction that's
beautiful man that's a serious thing to
build a city
like how do you get the funding for that
besides Lady Gaga
it's more to preparation though right
you know so when you start dealing with
all these major developers globally and
then you start dealing with the studies
like from the Environmental Studies all
the way down to soil studies yeah you're
gonna have sewage you gotta have a trash
department all that stuff it me I
learned so much in the process of this I
mean building a house is one thing but
when you're talking about building a
city the infrastructure that's attached
to that is on a different level then
we're talking about smart city with
technology that people don't even know
exists yet right you know so it was what
technology doesn't exist yet oh wait I
can't wait to invite you out to the city
okay
three a lot of it I got to keep under
close NDA conversations but for the most
part when y'all finally are invited it's
gonna be a treat well everyone get
internet oh yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah
everyone don't have internet that's what
I'm saying that's beautiful how many
square miles one square mile one square
mile so it'll be very small community it
starts off but it it's set up to where
it could scale out wow yeah that's dope
man yeah well salute to you man you know
I'm excited about it though [ __ ] I'm
trying to go no you will what do you
mean you're definitely gonna be